[Applause]
a week on from the decision which
altered this country forever and small
town america is reeling
this is an organized outpouring of
sadness rage and determination
by women who say their rights are being
dismantled among them some motivated by
personal pain
hadley was 12 years old when she was
impregnated by her stepfather
[Applause]
the abuse happened for a long time and
i'm lucky that it was only one pregnancy
and i had the choice and i feel like
everybody in that situation needs to
have the choice
how did it make you feel when you saw
the supreme court had overturned roe
versus wade i was sick
my heart broke for the little girl that
i used to be and for the other little
girls that are still out there because
it happens and it's not just a fantasy
it's not just something that only
happens in the movies it's real and it
does happen
in this vast land a legal patchwork of
abortion haves and have-nots is taking
shape
in kentucky the right to choose was
stripped away then temporarily restored
by a legal restraining order but it's
unlikely to last long this clinic will
soon be empty the medical professionals
who practice here sent home
marjorie has worked at emw for six years
it's very confusing these patients were
actually in disbelief and shock
not knowing all of the publicity we have
had about this anticipated here uh
result
uh court results so
these women are are desperate they're
often not aware of impending legislation
for some the reversal of abortion rights
gives rise to opportunity b side u is
one of hundreds of crisis pregnancy
centers in america
experts accuse these centers of giving
misleading information to discourage
women from getting abortions so usually
when people arrive at life house the
first thing they notice when they come
in is our baby wall
and this is our what we call our wall of
fame many of the women who are treated
at b side u are referred here to this
maternity home run by evangelical
christians in the last week they've had
a 50 increase in normal core levels we
have served
age wise as young as 13 and up to about
38 years old should a 13 year old who's
been the victim of rape be carrying her
child would it actually be the kind of
thing to allow her to terminate her
pregnancy safely and help her recover
from that trauma the trauma of sexual
abuse i can tell you from the the
experiences that we've had here i was
not personally involved with those but i
know in both situations those babies
were placed for adoption with loving
families and so i think that gives that
that young mom an opportunity to make a
decision that fits her best
abortion is an issue which is so
polarizing there will be no equilibrium
here only ugly and deepening division
martha kellner sky news kentucky
[Applause]